why did you write party girl
I wrote party girl when I was four years
sober and I realized the pr about
recovery was so bad and that if I had
had any idea how fun and funny
um and joyful recovery would be I
wouldn't have had to go as low as I did
and so I thought what if I could tell a
story if I can help one person see that
it's not recovery is not the end of life
but the beginning I will have done
something good
how long did it take you to write it I
wrote party girl very quickly I had no
idea how to write a book I just was very
Brazen and just was like well I've read
novels I will just write this and so I
started writing it and I actually had
one friend who was a novelist and I was
with her one day and she was saying to
me oh God when I started off I didn't
have a clue I mean I didn't even know
novels had a three-act structure and I
remember going you didn't and then I
race home and I look and I have like 400
pages of one act I had no idea there was
supposed to be a structure I didn't know
anything and so that was the process of
you know what Stephen King calls killing
Your Darlings and I just you know got
rid of excised 350 pages that day
and this was in the mid 90s the I wrote
the book I I got sober in 2000 and I
started and I wrote party girl in 2004
sold it to harpercollins in 2005 and it
came out in 2007. and where did you
actually write the book oh physically
where was I I was in my apartment on
Sweetser Avenue in um in West Hollywood
and anybody who's lived in La everyone's
either lived on sweets or Sycamore or
has dated somebody who's lived on
sweetstar Sycamore it's just an LA thing
tell me about the bidding war for the
book I know I'm jumping ahead a little
bit oh it was so exciting a bidding war
might be over staining things but it was
this completely Cinderella experience
because I had been working on this book
and literally an agent emails me out of
the blue and says I really like your
magazine work so it wasn't completely
out of the blue because I was well known
as a magazine writer and he said I I
think you're really funny if you ever
have a book let me know and I write them
back and say that's crazy I just
finished writing a book he said I'm
gonna be in L.A tomorrow let's sign and
I said fantastic and the next day I wake
up and there's an email from a different
agent and she says I just read a bunch
of your magazine stories I think you're
really talented if you ever have a book
tell me so I write her back and I say
that is so crazy I'm going to sign with
an agent literally walking out the door
and she said send me your phone number
and she called me and she she said do me
a favor do not sign with this person
today give me one day I'll cancel the
rest of my day and I'll read your book
if I don't like it you don't have a
problem go sign with him if I like it
you've got to give me a shot and so I
went to lunch with this guy I said I
know I said I was signing but I'm not
signing and she loved the book and she
said I can sell this and the way we're
gonna do this is if you just give a book
to editors they they take forever to
read it so I'm gonna say Anna's come to
town in two days so if you want a shot
at this you got to meet her and you have
to have read it before you meet with her
and I said but I'm not coming to town in
two days and she said well the worst
that can happen is you'll lose money on
a ticket and a hotel but I think I can
sell this so and that was a lot of money
to me at the time so I go to New York I
go to these two meetings with her and
then on my second day we get a call from
Regan books and Regan was like Judith
Regan in the 90s was the biggest deal
Pub publisher
my wildest dreams I didn't think that I
could attract a Judith Regan we get a
call when I'm already there and they say
Judith Regan not her herself although
anyway they said Regan wants to meet
with you so we go in we meet with them I
go home and I and and pillar my agent
says you know we'll know by Monday all
weekend long I'm just like I promise
I'll be happy for the rest of my life if
this book can sell she calls me Monday
morning and she tells me that the two
places pass
I'm devastated and then you know I'm
like the dream's over and she calls me
back she goes reading books made an
offer and and I and I did say I'm going
to be happy for the rest of my life and
I was for about two weeks and then I
realized oh no thing ever actually makes
you happy
at any point in the editors reading the
book or Judith Regan reading the book
did they say can you tone it down a
little bit or can you ramp it up a
little bit
you know they never said tone it down
you know the one thing they said toned
down I I talked about like God and
spirituality and they were like that
really makes people uncomfortable and
this is of course two years before a
book called Eat Pray Love Comes Out
nobody's freaked out about God At All by
then but that was the one thing they
wanted me to tone down in fact the note
I got when they bought the book was
and I'm not saying this in a
self-aggrandizing way they were just
like it's so perfect it's like you don't
you didn't make any mistakes because I
come from a world of being a writer and
an editor and you don't you turn in work
that you have edited and re-edited and
re-edited and I don't know that the book
world was used to that they were used to
typos so yeah all I had to do was like
take out some of the god stuff and we
were good is that because they thought
that the the some of the topics in it
maybe the salacious Parts wouldn't mix
with the religion I don't know I think
that there are certain words that freak
people out and God is one of them and so
I think that Publishers just like many
people just want to take the safest
route they want to not alienate people
not freak people out maybe they didn't
think it went with all the like crazy
sex and drugs and rock and roll stuff
but but I I just said sure whatever you
want you guys know
how soon after the book was published
did you sell the movie rights the
there was an interest in the movie
rights before the book came out and I'm
not entirely sure how it happened but
sort of knowledge about the book and its
topic leaked out so there was interest
you know between a publisher acquiring a
book and releasing it it's like a year
or two it just takes forever so during
that time I live in Hollywood I was
hearing from people so I I signed with
CAA CAA was interested in representing
the book
um and so
I the the actual story about what
happened is I got this agent who
couldn't have cared less couldn't have
cared less so there everybody who made
an offer told me they had to pursue and
pursue and pursue him to even get a call
back other friends told me they were
like your book landed on my desk with no
cover letter and no explanation so in
spite of the lack of interest of my
agent there was a bidding war over it
um but it was it was really frustrating
when you're a small like you know when
you're at one of those big agencies and
you're not a huge huge star that's what
happens but
um but yeah and so
the story of the movies amazing do you
want me to go into that now okay so so
the very first offer
um we got a mother-daughter team who had
a deal at Sony said to me they came to
me and they were wooing me and we had
lunch at this place called Michael's in
New York which is probably long gone but
it was this fancy publishing place and
they said if you go with us we will get
whatever screenwriter you want and I was
obsessed with Reality Bites so I said if
you can get the woman who wrote Reality
Bites to write my that my story I'm in
and they come back and they said we got
her her name's Helen Childress she's
excited here's your check and they
optioned it for twenty thousand dollars
which to me now is a fortune because now
they don't really pay anything for
options but at the time I didn't know
anything I was like great
so then everybody's very excited we're
talking about Lindsay Lohan who was a
big star at the time and they wanted to
sell it to Lifetime and I just thought
this sounds great this sounds like it's
going to be made and other offers were
coming in but I was like committed to
that one so with that one
then one day I email the mother-daughter
team I don't hear back I text them I
don't hear back
um I never hear anything it's all very
Hollywood and one day I get an email
from CA that says congratulations your
rights have reverted back to you and I
wrote back and I said what does this
mean never heard pack Google it it means
oh your movie wanted to turn around it
means like this is not good news and so
years pass and I was a freelance
magazine writer still and one time I
wrote a story about this experience
saying
um oh and it was all about Reality Bites
and how Troy Dyer who was the main
character in Reality Bites how he ruined
my whole like identification about
dating and how I was always seeking Troy
die or the most screwed up man ever and
I put as an aside I heard a rumor that
the woman who wrote Reality Bites wrote
the party girl script but I never even
found out if that was true sometimes
reality really does bite
Helen Childress saw the story and emails
me and says oh my god did you seriously
never see the script that I wrote of
party girl and I wrote back and said I
didn't even think they were telling the
truth I never even heard from them again
and she sent me the script so there it
is like early so it's like 2011 I'm
reading my favorite screenwriters
version of my book which is based on my
life from 10 years before it was the
most surreal experience ever and I said
to her oh let's let's get the movie
going again but when it once it's in
turn around
um it's that's almost impossible so do
you think the lesson though among others
is that
word gets out without you knowing how
and also no one tells you anything
yeah I mean Hollywood's an evil place
I'm sure everyone knows that but you
know it's it's basically you know when I
have a book a story like this which has
been around now for 15 years and I have
seen every incarnation of producer
coming along and I'm whined and I'm
dying not really wine but you know and
they're just like this is gonna be it
we're gonna do this and we're gonna go
there and then literally you never hear
from them again I've now lived in La for
so long that I'm used to this sort of
treatment I'm just like oh okay so you
don't you don't you you never hear again
you don't we don't really live in a
Hollywood is not a place where anybody
even really tells you when they've gone
off and moved on to the next hot thing
you just have to figure it out
how did you get a meeting with Martin
scorsese's producer
um this is a great story I am friends
with this couple who have these
get-togethers in LA with hundreds of
people where basically they'll sort of
interview
usually famous people and everybody's
watching and then they sometimes have
friends or just people with interesting
careers so they were interviewing me in
front of this crowd of about a hundred
people at their place in in Bel Air and
they were just interviewing me about
publishing and why should people write
books and somebody came up to me
afterwards and he said
um are you a screenwriter because you
talk like a screenwriter and I said no
but I have this book that would make the
best movie and he said well great I'm a
producer and that was his name is Niels
Joel and we were uh you know we worked
together I mean it was a long time it
was a couple years where he tried to
sell it and he wasn't able to
um but yeah he's great
how does a book or novel get on the
radar of Hollywood and Hollywood
producers
it is a okay a book gets on the radar
either because it sells like crazy
um it doesn't sell like crazy but gets a
lot of buzz like party girl the it
didn't sell that many copies but a lot
of people were talking about it or
because a book scout finds it and I
think with El James and 50 Shades of
Gray it really opened up Hollywood to
this idea that a book does not have to
be traditionally published for it to
make a movie and then Andy Weir wrote
The Martian and then
um so so
people can't producers can't just look
at what is on the New York Times
bestseller list what's in airport
bookstores they actually have to like
have a much wider swath of where they're
looking to find the books
why do you think Hollywood keeps buying
the rights to your book but not making
the movie
Hollywood loves to buy the rights to
things and not make them
um I think you know it's probably three
percent of the books that are optioned
are actually made and you know I just
think that everybody in Hollywood
there's somebody else that they're
answering to and most people are sort of
coming from a place of fear and what
just hit and what you know and so they
just want to have as many options as
possible literally book options as
possible knowing that they're only going
to take a tiny fraction of them
and tie them up so that others can't
yeah get to it before they do okay yeah
that's interesting when I um this is
this is kind of interesting when I used
to do coverage when my first jobs when I
first moved to LA so I would read
screenplays and you know basically write
book reports on them and I remember
there was this book
um that came out and I read coverage on
it and I just thought this is the worst
book I have ever read and I wrote
coverage saying this is the worst book I
have ever read this is why I get called
into the office the next day and my boss
says to me there was a betting War over
that book yesterday and it sold for
three million dollars now why are you
saying what you said and I said because
it's true it's terrible I later many
years later became friends with the
studio head who had made that who bought
it for three million dollars and he goes
oh yeah that book was terrible I had to
keep it out of someone else's hands so
that's why we did it so
um you know there are all sorts of
reasons that Hollywood digs into its
Deep Pockets to buy things